kim kardashian spilled all about pete
davidson including whether or not we can
expect another kardashian wedding
do you ever think marriage will be in
the cards again for you i think i'm
definitely going to be really cautious
because i you know have proven that
maybe i'm not the best at it and i don't
want to make that mistake again
sometimes i think should i just be in
one of those relationships like goldie
hawn and kurt russell it seems to be
working out for them kim opened up about
everything from pete to parenting
including when she introduced her
boyfriend of nearly eight months to her
and kanye's four kids i consulted with a
few therapists and friends that have
been through it so i definitely wanted
to wait six months
and that was like the marker
other revelations from kim's two
segments on the today show this morning
more details on that infamous met gala
moment in marilyn monroe's dress we keep
seeing stuff like the dress is ruined
the dress is this all of that is uh is
not true no and i mean ripley's were so
we worked together so well there was
handlers and gloves that put it on me
it was such a process i showed up to the
red carpet in a robe and slippers
and i put the dress on on the bottom of
the carpet oh my gosh went up the stairs
i probably had it on for three minutes
four minutes
and then i changed right at the top
kim also says she continued to lose
weight after initially dropping 16
pounds in three weeks to fit into the
iconic dress i'm down 21 pounds now i'm
not trying to lose any more weight but i
have more energy than ever i cut out so
much sugar a lot of junk food i was
eating i didn't even realize that a lot
of fried foods and i just completely
changed my lifestyle
[Music]